So by now you have heard the news that Dave Grohl is a piece of shit
and he cheated on his wife and had a baby outside of their marriage.
He's always been a piece of shit,
but now it's, like, official.
He even obtained a divorce attorney
for announcing that he had a baby outside of his marriage.
And that's exactly why, like,
you shouldn't fall for the like, oh,
I'm such a loving dad. These men use their kids as fucking props.
They just want the cute fucking picture with the cute fucking kid.
Like, if it's a fucking puppy or a plant.
It's fucking disgusting.
Acting like you're a decent fucking father
just for the world to fucking see,
but behind the scenes, you're a piece of shit.
Treating their mother like shit,
cheating on her, having babies here,
there and everywhere is fucking shameful and disgusting.
And I would be fucking embarrassed to have him as my father
and so fucking embarrassed to be his fucking wife.
So just don't fall for it.
It doesn't. All the fucking cutesy shit,
all the acting and playing. Fuck those dads.